Hausa Gomez - daddy back then the joy of
the Christmas spirit you and I are today
going to clean what you're not excited
by cleaning your room looks like [ __ ] so
you might have heard of this game is
called Becerra it's a game about muffin
cans you know item games you always make
a mess
well you're the guy cleans up this [ __ ]
so I guess that's what we got a Timmy
what happened to you
Timmy why don't you answer me Timmy I
could take the walls all right we got a
mop this [ __ ] up one chip
daddy daddy daddy what what stay happy -
no fight m8 oh my god
packages for me oh gosh I'm making a
mess this is pretty much how I clean in
real life anyway what is this what
unload this folks oh okay
this is work I guess I'll take him and
then I dispose no okay how do I activate
that we got what that's awesome
see this guy's fine he's not dead like
what if this guy's able to do this I
thought no you stuck to the wall aren't
you oh damn it alright Tim it's gotta go
sit down nice and tight there you go
like it looks so happy
stop looking so happy don't make me mop
your ass oh god that is creepy man
no present for you ah you don't know me
don't judge me
well it's time to dispose of him guess
you put him back in right what I got
started how am I gonna clean all this by
myself I have better things to do okay
fine what is this that's a little high
that's adorable
what is it oh all right put you down
there we go all right the system mopping
Oh Fox say I've got damage I'm getting
that one okay pick up pick up bite it's
[ __ ] stuck there we go all right put
you down and it's mop there all right
let's clean up this mess
there we go much better this is pretty
relaxing okay
so much work to be done before Christmas
this water is dirty now isn't it oh my
god damn it all right what do I do with
this I put it back all right you take it
what are you even doing here burning oh
I can't burn it
yeah roasted Tim it's just the way I
like aren't you happy Timmy aren't you
happy
what shut up Timmy you can't speak more
presses for me not some Jack's back the
slack spaniel
what is this mommy got me only 23
percents and a soccer field cake I hate
her chops what a dick
the low pays in crypto Santa Claus wood
burns and holy [ __ ] how come you're
Santa right in front of kitty can we do
something with this can we work with
this cut damn it
Oh Oh why don't we put it why don't we
put it
then I die dying is part of the job I
guess
gosh starting now I gotta clean up boy
more of them really seriously clay clay
I wouldn't even clean my own room this
well seriously what happens in the
basement oh gosh oh gosh sorry about
that
oh he's trying to defend himself with
nerf guns
oh come here give me a hug give me a big
mad that is this raw dogs
don't worry again Santa Santa isn't real
anyway I hope it's not now at least did
he [ __ ] jest on the wall or some [ __ ]
a drum a like one of your french girls
let's gather all our friends oh nice
haha thanks for me thank you
I mean your face I think yeah that's for
that space don't hurt stop creepy but I
got away
ah so now our little and friends have
gathered for the PAHO how about you now
I know our friends house and friends
have gathered it's time to set up the
party now gotta let it go
jab it right now we just mentioned of a
mess
I found they would go up I guess you
can't kill what has been killed
please is never gonna be clean now what
if I burn myself I don't want to live
anymore take my doll hey everyone hates
safety class that fat little [ __ ]
okay damn it can I just burn you how
does water burn someone explain that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
if you look weirdly that shirt looks
like a dick I'm just just throwing that
[ __ ] out there alright so now that you
can see that guy clearly cleaned
everything I mean yes of course so I
think we're done with the game it's
actually really fun getting them
multiplayer and stuff like that so it's
pretty cool they'd like me to know we're
watching it's this kind of coma mood
today
and Merry Christmas friends I hope you
don't spend your Christmas cleaning Oh
dead bodies
I guess row face